um everyone i'm sorry should i have your
attention please
thank you
ah
hi sorry i just have an announcement to
make
um
okay
i have learned a lot about indian
culture tonight
but i have learned even more
about love
and i know you're all thinking who is
this crazy gringo and what is he talking
about
well i'm not crazy
maybe i'm crazy in love
so without further ado
carol
carol stills
i would like you
to do me the honor
of making me
your husband
oh michael
what are you saying
can we talk about this in private
i didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
[Music]
see ya bye
thanks
yes you did it you got it nailed it
nailed it come here
[Music]
i am really
thrilled
let's go
what let's go going okay where are we
going doesn't matter
go to the
go-go
okay
[Music]
do you want to do that
it's disgusting
you know i have soft teeth how could you
say that
oops
excuse me for a second
so
how do you guys know each other
i was just babysitter and now you guys
are dating
purely carnal that's all you need to
know
would you write down your email because
i have just
so many questions
email
nevermind okay
all right
there we go
oh
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no
no
i'm gonna leave it up i think it ties
the whole room together
okay
[Music]
jan thinks hunter is very talented
you know what
i don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist pfd i'm a screenwriter
and i'm a candle maker but you don't
hear me bragging about it no all you do
is you get me
to try to work on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man i would love
to burn your candles you burn it you buy
it oh good i'll be your first customer
you're hardly my first
[Music]
that is a two hundred dollar plasma
screen tv you just killed good luck
paying me back on your zero dollars a
year salary plus benefits babe
okay
do you want me to stop dating your mom
is that how we're gonna get past this
cause i will
yes
well that is not gonna happen then why'd
you even offer because i assumed that
you want me to be happy because i want
you to be happy michael let me make this
very easy for you i could give it about
your happiness stop dating my mother
you know what i'm gonna start dating her
even harder what's that supposed to mean
you know what it means
hey shut it yep
something wow
that's exciting hey michael hey
sorry to interrupt you um
i actually have something very important
to talk to you about well business
related it can wait i lied it's personal
it's about me and jim
i just you're the only person i can talk
to jim is her husband
and and they're having problems and so
she comes to me we're not having
problems but it is personal and i will
yes
yes i desperately want to speak with you
about my sex life
oh my god look at how cheap street level
rooms are am i the only person who
enjoys people watching i need you to
sign this
so bad okay weirdo
i love
this idea is neat i've never been it
sounds lovely yeah i think it'll be a
nice trip we're going to get a lot done
you're going to want to look at the date
on that
oh wow look at golfing are you a golfer
i am but i i gave my clubs away swear
too much
[Laughter]
hey you okay yeah i just remembered that
i have to go to the bathroom
bam absolutely
damn it
hello holly
whoa
what are you doing you don't uh
you don't have to do that i mean we have
already put together chairs that's how
we buy them actually
trying to adjust the lumbar support on
toby's chair and
that made this up down lever thing not
work and then i took the whole chair
apart and that
is the story of me on the floor it's
pretty good right i'm going to tell the
movie rights and the sequel
woman stands at desk and works
so
i have no idea how you
how you sit like that
yoga
sit on floor and put together a cherry
wheel
yo da
um
pass curvy metal piece you will
so are you in town this weekend
because i'm not i'm not
i'm not going to be in town uh
going out of town oh so you can't make
my orgy
kidding
i'm kidding
yeah
let's go in here
hi guys
this is where our love faces its
toughest test
after this it's just smooth sailing for
the rest of our lives
holly
will you marry me
no
marry me holly
no that guy's got more than he can
handle as it is will you marry me
no that marriage would be a sham will
you marry me no easy no will you marry
me no that would be hot i would pay to
see that will you marry me holly
no
only one that i was kind of worried
about
oh
this is where i fell in love with you
and this is where i ask you to marry me
it started
[Laughter]
me will you be
your wife becoming
evil eyes
[Applause]
thank you
so guys guys guys guys
we're moving to colorado
all of us
yep
wait what
holly has to go back to colorado i'm
going with her i'm leaving
you